i'm not a revolutionary
his calculations are correct the empire
is dying
order will vanish wars will be endless
hey guys pete here we've got a
full-length
teaser for foundation from apple tv plus
and i'm gonna break that down today
we also got our first detailed
description of the series which reads
when revolutionary dr harry selden
predicts the impending fall of the
empire
he and a band of loyal followers
ventured to the far
reaches of the galaxy to establish the
foundation
in an attempt to rebuild and preserve
the future of civilization
enraged by harry's claims the ruling
cleons
a long line of emperor clones fear their
grasp on the galaxy may be weakening as
they're forced to reckon with the
potential reality of losing their legacy
forever
i had a pair of reactions watching this
video for the first time
first this looks ambitious and amazing
second there's gonna be some major
changes from the source material which
may not be a bad
thing there's a long list of reasons why
this series has never been adapted for
the screen which i discussed in detail
in my breakdown for the first
trailer translating asimov's ideas
in a way that would be entertaining for
a tv audience
was always going to be a challenge
because there's several time
jumps and new characters are constantly
being introduced
the question was never if they would
make some changes but rather can they
make the right changes
so that it'll work as an entertaining tv
show but stay true to the overarching
themes of asimov's work
so i'll break down what we see here
without giving away any major spoilers
for the ending of the series which does
rely heavily on twists along the way
at the end i'll discuss what i think is
going on with some of the changes
and what that might mean for the
adaptation
the teaser opens with a shot of what
appears to be the emperor's palace on
the capital city of trantor
the clue here beyond its size is the
gardens
the empire's capital is an ecumenopolis
the entire surface is built up it's
covered with man-made structures
and the imperial palace was the only
place where you might see
green spaces like this inside we see an
old man approaching an
area where clones are produced and nato
demarzel
who served as a first minister to the
emperor in the books
here she tells the eldest of the living
clones that he can't be there
he responds that he can't be the first
to want to see his youngest self
and that cuts to a sequence of someone
flipping a coin where we get a look at
the emperor clones at different ages
the old man is brother dusk and they're
all clones of the emperor cleon
there are three versions at any given
time the youngest is dawn
and the middle is day the show runner
david s goyer has explained that the
different versions have
an interesting relationship the older
one raises and nurtures the younger
who can literally see an older version
of themselves which is reassuring in a
way
at the same time there's a struggle with
each one wanting to prove their unique
by this time there have been 14 of them
all
living in the shadow of the original
brother day
says our genetic dynasty has reigned for
almost four
centuries and as he's talking we see a
fleet of ships attacking a planet
this isn't something that happens in the
book so it's not clear why the attack is
going
on or what this planet is he continues
the might of the imperium has brought
peace to thousands of worlds
but the beliefs of one man now threaten
the empire's very existence
the man he's talking about is harry
selden and his beliefs in
air quotes are based on the science of
psycho history
a couple of days ago i put out a video
on psycho history if you're new to the
series and want to learn about it
or if it's just been a while and you
want a refresher
we hear harry selden say i'm not a
revolutionary which is in contrast
to the log line that i read at the
beginning of the video but
it is true harry selden has seen that
the
empire will fall and that's predicted by
psycho history
his main goal is not to upset the order
but to minimize the suffering that's
coming
after things fall apart he wants to get
humanity back
on track quicker and establishes the
foundations to help accelerate the rise
of a new
empire later in the trailer we hear him
describe what's coming
he says order will vanish wars will be
endless
you can't save yourselves but you can
save your legacy
beyond the mention of legacy this is
pretty consistent with how things play
out in the books
the fall of the empire is supposed to
lead to 30 000 years of barbarism and
chaos
selden thinks he can shorten that to a
thousand years using psycho history
but no one understands it at this point
and there's no real motivation for the
people in power to listen to him
that's where galdornik comes in she's a
brilliant mathematician that harry hired
to help him work on psycho history
in the first trailer we saw her journey
from her home world and we saw her
meeting with selden for the first time
there's a couple more glimpses of that
here
in this trailer we see her looking at
the equations through the prime radian
and saying his calculations are correct
the empire is dying
so seldon has this situation where he
can see what's going to happen
no one really wants to listen to him no
one really understands what he's saying
and galdorna can actually understand the
math she's there to start working with
him
but still seems impartial since she
hasn't started yet
this all lends credence to her
professional opinion on the equations
where it looks like the tv show will
diverge from the source material
it looks like there's a lot more tension
in the empire
and possibly even some revolutionary
stuff going on
on trantor we hear gal tell the emperor
that
only the psycho historians can shorten
the darkness
and we hear the emperor say that selden
has a following
people that hinge their hopes on every
word that seldon utters
words have a way of fanning into
wildfires
i mentioned that there wasn't much
motivation for the people in power to
listen to selden
in the books no one believes the empire
will fall because there are no blatant
warning signs
they call harry raven seldom because
he's issuing warnings
and they just don't see a collapse as
possible obviously the warnings could
cause
problems for those in charge and based
on what we see
here it looks like they may add that
element to the tv show
we also get a couple more looks at
terminus and salver hardin
in the timeline of the books salver is
born on the planet where the foundation
is established
and becomes the mayor about 50 years
after they arrived there
we get a couple shots of the planet that
look like they were filmed in iceland
and our first look at some of the people
living there i presume the time jump is
still going to happen
so these parts of the trailer happen
decades after the scenes we saw with gal
and harry
one of the things that seemed totally
foreign to me was this shot of salver
walking up to this thing
sort of floating above the surface of
the planet it turns out this
is the vault which book readers will
know what that is but i won't spoil it
here
according to the showrunner no one knows
where it came from
it was there on terminus when the
colonists arrived and it's one of the
mystery boxes of the show
we'll definitely find out what's in the
vault in the season
although there are other mysteries to
reveal about the vault in later seasons
this is something that plays an
important role in the books but they
made it look a little more dramatic
instead of just being something that
existed in their library
all we know is that salver has a very
special relationship to the bolt
so it turns out that she's the only
person that's able to approach the
object and he continues
that it has what we call a null field
which is designed to keep people away
if you try to approach it you get
headaches you get nosebleeds eventually
you pass out but for some reason
salvor harding can walk through the null
field she can touch the vault
there's something special about her and
she has a relationship that we're going
to explore
over the course of the first season and
that's pretty much all the big stuff
that we see
in the trailer there's a lot of cool
looking shots in this
with some pretty impressive graphics and
special effects
it certainly looks a lot more
action-packed than the
beginning of the original foundation
trilogy and we'll have to see if that's
an improvement that's capable of
bringing a lot of new people to the
series
a lot of the initial negative takes i
saw about the trailer
that were coming from long time fans of
the series
were along the lines of this is a
completely different thing from the
books
or that it was evidence that they were
adapting the prequels rather than
starting
from the first book of the original
trilogy i wouldn't agree with either of
those really
the prequels as written covered nearly
50 years of selden's life
after he first arrived on trantor in his
30s
to my eyes jared harris looks to be the
same age in all the scenes
and while there may be flashbacks my
thinking is that they're going to be
extending the period of time
after gal dornick arrives on trantor
which makes up the first chapter of the
first book
maybe they're dipping into the epilogue
from forward the foundation
but at least in this i don't see much
evidence that they're adapting the two
prequels in full
and i think that's probably for the best
they could be adding some of what
happens on terminus
after the foundation gets going that's
something that we don't see in the book
we get an understanding of what harry
selden's trying to do
and then we just jump to the period of
time where it's already established
there
this is where the idea of the emperor
being essentially
immortal with this idea of cloning might
work one of the challenges to adapting
the series always seemed like it would
have been
difficult to follow for viewers with the
cast of characters that was always
changing
tv series are built around characters
that you follow for seasons
i had the initial knee-jerk reaction of
this is not foundation when i saw the
clones
so i understand the sentiment of
thinking that it looks completely
different but if it helps to keep some
of the actors consistent let's see what
they do with it
the core is still there harry selden is
still developing
psycho history and getting things ready
to be put into motion before the time
skips start
to happen there is one character who is
still a mystery this guy we've seen in
both
trailers and what looks like trantor's
heat sinks to me
and we see him running around with
galdornik they haven't revealed his name
and my best
guess is that he's similar to one of the
mathematicians who worked with harry
named hugo
in prelude to foundation harry found him
working as a low-level laborer in the
heatsinks
and realized he had a gift for
mathematics he would be
rather old this guy's obviously still
young but otherwise he just seems like
he's there so that gal has someone
playing opposite her
why not make it a mathematician most of
this looks pretty promising visually
it looks like they have the budget to
represent what it might look like
20 000 years in the future where humans
have colonized the entire galaxy
can't say that i'm disappointed at all
in the way that this looks
i guess what i'm less enthusiastic about
is this sense of psycho history bringing
about revolutionary fervor
i mean i'm down for a revolution i'm not
against that idea but there was
something unique about how
things unfolded under the radar over
generations in foundation
the idea that people have to somewhat be
kept in the dark about what the
psycho-historical analyses predict
means that it does require some faith
but it doesn't really cause a stir
in the books with normal people i
realize they need to make it exciting
and bring in some action for
entertainment value
but i hope it doesn't lose what made the
book so satisfying in the process
salver seems like the best example of
this the character in the
books was really just clever a badass
sure but not in the action hero sense
he figured out what was going on around
him when everyone else was paying
attention to the wrong
things there was no error of him being a
chosen one or anything like that
here it seems like they added that idea
pretty explicitly
and when i see the female version
running around with the ragtag group of
something like
freedom fighters with weapons strapped
on their backs
it does make me feel a little nervous
it's not that those things won't be
entertaining to watch
it's just that there's already a lot of
stories like that out there
that said i've definitely argued that
there would need to be some changes to
make this work as a tv show
and after seeing this trailer i'm still
excited to see what they come up with
the tagline of savior legacy seems a
little peculiar as well
they're certainly upping the role of the
emperor so i guess there's that angle
one of the things asmob was interested
in though
was the idea of history repeating itself
so i'll be curious to see how they
settled on the idea of legacy
and i think that's a good place to leave
things i've already made a couple other
foundation videos
so i didn't want to rehash everything
that i've already covered in those
and i'll probably be making some more
soon because there's a lot of different
ideas kicking around in my head now that
we've seen
more of the footage let me know what you
think in the comments
how do you feel about the trailer if you
want to talk book spoilers i'm all for
it but just please mark those
so that we're not giving away the big
twists in the series this early
if you're interested in picking the
books up the first three are a quick
read and i'll have some links to those
in the description
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon